Випробування рокостисканням пройдене це
та сама мить яку згодом Емануель макрон
назве моментом істини під час
нещодавньої зустрічі трампа та макрона у
Брюсель вони так сильно стиснули роки
один одного що під час позування для
фотографів було помітно як побіліли
кісточки їх пальців помірятися силами
люблять як Трамп так і президенти
Туреччини та Росії - розповів макрон але
він ставиться до цього спокійно хоча
свою посаду макрон обійняв нещодавно він
уже встиг отримати репутацію впевненого
гравця у зовнішньополітичній сфері Хоч
він робив компліменти на адресу трампа
на самітах НАТО та Великої сімки макрон
сповідує однозначно про європейську
позицію у зовнішньополітичних
економічних та екологічних
питаннях свій перший закордонний візит
Емануель макрон здійснив до Берліна ще
за виборчою кампанією у Франції
німецький Уряд не робив таємницію з того
що макрон є для нього найбільш бажаним
кандидатом а тому у Берліні на нього
чекав теплий прийом попри деякі
розбіжності з економічних питань Ангела
Меркель та Емануель макрон
продемонстрували єдність в усіх ключових
зовнішньополітичних питаннях це це
стосується перш за все позиції щодо
України її територіальної цілісності а
також невизнання статусу Криму в складі
Росії при цьому тривалість режиму
санкцій проти Москви Берлін і Париж
чітко пов'язують з реалізацією кремлем
своїх зобов'язань в межах Мінських угод
незважаючи на розбіжності з Москвою
Париж та Берлін готові з нею
співпрацювати але лише тоді коли така
взаємодія відповідає інтересам країн
Великої
сімки останні двосторонні переговори
російського президента з лідером Франції
на французькій території відбулися майже
5ть років тому в червні 12-го року
нинішню зустріч Москва та Париж
анонсували лише за тиждень до візиту
Путіна офіційно вона приврочена до
відкриття виставки у версаельському
палаці з нагоди трьохсотріччя відвідин
Франції Петром пе і це зручна можливість
для макрона зустрітися з Путіним без
офіційного прийому в єлисейському палаці
тема переговорів двосторонні відносини
боротьба з тероризмом і головне
врегулювання криз в Сирії та в Україні
експерти не очікували від нинішньої
зустрічі якихось конкретних результатів
адже ще нещодавно в ході виборчих
перегонів штаб макрона звинувачував
російські державні ЗМІ в поширені
фейкових новин з метою дискредитації
макрона та на підтримку його конкурентів
А за місяць до першого туру
президентських виборів у Франції
Володимир Путін навіть прийняв у Кремлі
кандидатку від правапопулістського
національного фронту Марін лепен під час
виборів макрон багато разів заявляв що
не поділяє цінності Путіна і називав дії
Москви в Сирії та в Україні серйозним
порушенням міжнародного права щоправда
при цьому макрон завжди наголошував на
важливості збереження діалогу з Москвою
для урегулювання цих
конфліктів